the book of
life I've already addressed this in
previous sessions if you listen to the
most recent session I said if you read
the Bible carefully if you read the
Bible
carefully what you find is that every
creature's name is in the Book of Life
and this shows God's
intention and desire to save every
creature so God Reveals His desire
intention to save every creature that
comes into existence which is why their
name is in the book of life but as they
turn away and refuse to turn to Christ
then God blots out their names and I
already gave you the evidence in the
previous session but let's look at the
evidence
again all right now biblicist put Exodus
32-33 32-33 if you don't mind
brother yet now if thou wil forgive
their sin and if not me I pray thee out
of thy book which thou Hast written now
notice what the Lord says and the Lord
said unto Moses whosoever hath sinned
against me him will I blot out of my
book did you catch it him will I blot
out of my book him I will blot out of my
book so God blots out those who turn
away from the Lord blaspheme the Lord
cut themselves off from the Lord or
refuse to turn to the Lord did we see
that everyone got got that
part so now
Protestant
hero get with the hero brother can you
put Revelation 3 verse5 Revelation
chapter
3:5 if you can he's a hero man he's no
hero did you ever know that you're my
hero okay Revelation
3:5 okay he that overcometh the same
shall be clothed in white rayment and I
will not blot out his name out of the
book of life but I will confess his name
before my father and before his angels
so it's not an issue of writing their
names in it's an issue of erasing their
name you get it it's not an issue of
writing their names in it's an issue of
erasing their
names
right everyone got it it's not about
writing their names in it's about
erasing p 69 27-28 Psalm 69
27-28 add iniquity unto their iniquity
and let them not come into thy
righteousness let them be blotted out of
the book of the living and not be
written with the righteous did you catch
it again let them be blotted out of the
book of the living and not be written
with the righteous are you seeing the
pattern are you seeing the pattern the
patterns not their names are written in
its names are being blotted out meaning
their names are already in the
book their names already in the
book so here's the objection I've
already answered this objection but I'm
going to answer it again for your
benefit if you're paying attention now
let's regroup let's focus I got a lot of
meat to discuss if you're interested
because I got a couple hours and I'm G
to meet one of our brothers hey essay
Emanuel don't forget I'm meeting you
today God willing so make sure you show
up caral all right now here's the
passage that was quoted as a reputation
of my ex to Jesus as if I do not know of
these passages I'm not aware of them and
I haven't thought about
them Revelation
13:8 and all that dwell upon the Earth
shall worship Him whose names are not
written in the Book of Life of the lamb
slain from the foundation of the world
whose names are not written in the Book
of Life of the lamb slain from the
foundation of the world whose names are
not written The Book of Life of the lamb
slain from the foundation world did you
catch it those who worship the Beast and
His Image are those whose names are not
written in the Book of Life see Sam not
everyone's name is in the Book of Life
okay I'll answer that in a minute let's
go to Revelation 17
ver8 the Beast that thou sawest was and
is not and shall Ascend out of the
bottomless pit and go into predition and
they that dwell on the Earth shall
wonder whose names were were not written
in the Book of Life from the foundation
of World when they behold the Beast that
was and is not and yet is so here's the
objection see their names were not
written in the Book of Life from the
foundation of the world see not
everyone's name is in the Book of Life
no that's not what it's
saying let me now correct that
misinterpretation if scripture
interprets scripture and scripture
doesn't contradict here's what these
passages are saying in the context of
the Bible as a whole are we ready now to
focus in the context of the ible as a
whole
okay what these passages are saying is
that the Lamb's Book of
Life was written from the foundation of
the world it's not saying their names
wasn't written in the Book of Life from
the foundation of the world that is bad
exag Jesus it's saying this book of life
was a book that was there written from
the foundation of the world why because
that is the moment in time in which God
will summon all generations of creatures
so God has now written the names of all
who will come into being from the start
of creation what it's saying here is
that it's the book that was written from
the foundation of the world but the
names that are not written are names
that were eventually blotted out which
is why their names are no longer in the
Book of Life resulting in them following
the Beast you with me there before
before I move
on I'm going to repeat it
again if you read the passages carefully
it's saying that this book is the book
that was written from the foundation of
the world it's not saying their names
was not in the book from the foundation
of the world it's saying the book of
life was written from the foundation of
the world why are their names not there
not because their names were not written
from the start it's because their names
were it out so they're no longer in the
Book of Life which is why they succumb
to the Beast now the question is why
were their names blotted out from the
book A book written from the foundation
of the world is it because they were
predestined not to be there or have
their names blotted out no it's because
they refus to acknowledge God submit to
God they kept opposing God resisting his
truth they hated the truth of God and
loved the lie so God got fed up with
them and handed them over to their
disbelief where do we find this second
Thessalonians chapter 2 speaking of the
Beast second Thessalonians chapter 2
speaking of the Beast they called the
man of sin the man of lawlessness let's
read from 2 Thessalonians chapter 2: 3
to
8 I hope I'm making sense to you guys
let no man deceive you by any means for
that day shall not come except there
come a falling away first notice a
falling away first people falling away
from the faith perverting the
faith opposing the faith introducing
destructive damnable heresies in the
place of the truth that they had known a
following away first and that man of sin
be revealed the son of predition that's
the Beast of Revelation 13 and 17 who
opposeth and exalteth himself above all
that is called God or that is worship so
that he as God sth in the temple of God
showing himself that he is God remember
ye not that when I was it with you I
told you these
things and now you know that withholdeth
him what keeps him back that he might be
revealed in his time notice verse seven
and 8 for the mystery of iniquity
does already work only he who now let it
leth will let until he be taken out of
the way in other words the man of
lawlessness the signs already there that
he's about to show up but he's not
revealed yet because he's been
constrained until the appointed time and
when his time comes that which
constrains him will be removed so then
he'll appear and oppose God and demand
people to worship him that's the Beast
of Revelation 13 and 17 now notice verse
8 and then shall that Wicked be revealed
whom the Lord shall consume with the
spirit or breath of his mouth and shall
destroy with the brightness of his
coming now watch this verses 9
to2 2 Thessalonians 2:
9-12 watch
here even him whose coming is after the
working of Satan with all power and
signs and Wonder see this is a direct
parallel to Revelation 13 the Beast will
be empowered by Satan and the false
prophet will be empowered by Satan to do
miracles signs and wonders to deceive
people to believe the lie and with all
deceivableness of unrighteousness in
them that perish he those whose names
are not written in the Book of Life
notice who are they because they
received not the love of the truth truth
that they might be saved so you see
God's desire those whose names are not
written are those that God revealed the
truth to those that knew the truth and
God wanted to save but they didn't want
to be saved right because they did not
receive the love of the truth that they
might be saved and for this cause God
shall send them strong delusion that
they should believe a lie why that they
all might be them who believed not not
the truth but had pleasure and
unrighteousness do you got it now you
got it
everyone do you see that the people who
follow the Beast the people who worship
the Beast the people who fall for the
Miracles the signs and wonders that the
Beast does by Satan miracles to convince
them to believe his lie and blasphemy
are people that God had already revealed
the truth to shall KN God's desire that
he wants them to be saved but in instead
of responding to the truth they oppose
it they reject it they discard it
because they don't want the truth of God
they don't want the true God they'd
rather continue in their sin and R rry
so now God hands them over to the
desires of their
heart everyone got
it so if I interpret scripture in light
of script RT pay attention guys if I
interpret scripture in light of
scripture these
people whose names are not in the book
of life the reason why their names are
not there isn't because their names were
never there it's because they are
examples of individuals who hate God's
truth who oppose God's truth who hate
God and His True Word and his true
prophets so God has now fed up with them
they reached a level of repr where they
blashe the spirit so now God erases
their names and hands them over to the
desires of their
heart because remember what God said to
Moses Exodus
32:33 what did he say let's read it
again watch here let's read it again May
the numbers increase For Your Glory
father son Holy Spirit Lord
Jesus watch here the Protestant check
out okay and the Lord said to Moses
whosoever hath sinned against me him
will I blot out of my book so those who
worship the Beast and His
Image because they believe the miracles
signs and wonders that he does by the
power of Satan to convince them of his
lie and
blasphemy were they people whose names
were never written in or were their
names erased because they sinned against
God grieve the Holy Spirit blasphemed
the spirit and God has fed up with them
you with me
there so why does it say those whose
names are not written in the book of
life because their names were erased
it's not that their names were never in
it if you interpret scripture and light
of scripture and you don't believe
scripture contradicts itself then
reading it consistently can actually
everyone's name is in the Book of Life
everyone's name is in the book of life
so what happens is as God draws them by
the spirit as the spirit convicts them
to acknowledge their sinfulness and
their need to turn to Jesus the more
they resist the more they grieve the
spirit until they reach a point of
reprobation where the spirit is now
blasphemed and the spirit now is done
with them they reached the point of no
return now God hands them over to their
desires and erases their
names that's how you interpret these
passages